she gives a check
uh it's ready to see a king move with a
check
because uh in this position
we saw a discover check from the white
rook but the black king moved and again
not much to say here unfortunately no
progress the viking zig-zagging its way
back
the most cynical moves not allowing a
single chance right
and i mean the players i think they can
check on chess 24 on the play zone you
can scroll down and see the number of
moves you can count but i doubt jordan
would have spent his time doing that and
one more move
and after black's move
if i've counted correctly the next move
will mean that the game is a draw and
i'll automatically end the game i i
suppose in the chess 24 play zone there
you go yeah there we go
wow a long hard-fought game by
especially then ju wen jun fighting for
a win but eventually
a draw against jordan from forest and
that concludes day one in the charity
cup and round four in the preliminaries
what a day it's been some entertaining
chess and